after years of waiting the mood in
indonesia's people's representative
council was one of celebration
there's no place for sexual violence
house speaker puan maharani declared as
legislators passed a highly anticipated
bill into law which aims to create a
better legal framework for victims of
sexual abuse to secure justice
this law is so important all these years
there were so many victims who didn't
get justice
they endured trauma they were
criminalized and victimized
the law has been broadly welcomed by
rights groups around the country for
making the well-being of sexual abuse
victims a priority by offering
compensation and other support
there are many breakthroughs in this law
in the best interest of the victims
it also expands the definition of sexual
crimes to include different types of
abuse
firstly and foremost it actually
regulates sexual crimes or sexual
violence that previously are not
considered as criminal acts or
partially regulated
which includes sexual harassment
passing the bill wasn't easy supporters
faced a strong challenge from those who
are opposed to such laws
the bill had faced some backlash since
its early stages which caused delays in
getting it passed conservative political
parties and some religious groups were
against it saying it will encourage
adultery and sex outside
marriage bill was in jeopardy people
were saying it supports free sex and
opens the door for sexual deviants but
it was proven that narrative was not
true
several high-profile cases helped keep
the issue in public focus
last month a dean at a university in
northern indonesia was acquitted of all
charges after a female student said he
sexually harassed her
her lawyer said he welcomes the new
legislation
under the law a letter from a
psychologist can be used as evidence i
hope going forward no more perpetrators
of sexual violence will be set free
students at the university have held
regular rallies in support of the
student who made the allegations
like many they say they just want their
campus and the rest of indonesia to be a
safer place
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta